just took off morning ciao we'll talk
about the bus destination and yes okay
thank you and dress for the introduction
and thank the organizers for the
carnival tation today I'll talk about
robust situation and it's very
interesting relation to this generative
a diversity or nuts
so our spent the first topper talk to
talk about how you can use various
depths function to achieve optimal rate
of convergence for many estimation tasks
and the boobers epsilon contamination
model and then I will talk about how you
can actually optimize something that is
very similar to this function using the
technique of Ganz so the talk will be
focused on a Hoover's model where the
data's are generated from a mixture
distribution so for each observation
with 1 minus epsilon probability it is
drawn from the true model that you
assumed for the data and then another
excellent probability that is drawn from
an arbitrary distribution but you do not
know what it is so theta is the
parameter that we are interested in
estimating you can think of it as a low
dimensional parameter or it can be as
general as a nonparametric function or
even a density function itself depending
on the setting and our core epsilon the
contamination proportion and Q the
contamination distribution so let's
start by talking about the perhaps the
simplest model where you need to
estimate a very multivariate normal in
this situation so how can you do that
well the one of the most obvious
estimator is you can just take the
cordon wise median which is defined to
be the univariate median taking on each
coordinate a second choice is a Tukey's
median it is defined in a slightly more
complicated way basically you seek to
find the the univariate meeting or each
direction of U and then sort of using
this formula to combine all the
univariate
in terms of all directions so which
estimator is better well if you are
familiar with those old literature's in
1960s or - - - 80s especially those
papers in annals of statistics then one
of the most popular notion to assess the
robustness of estimators is called
breakdown point it is defined to be the
smallest proportion of the data that you
need to perturb or change so that you
can change the corresponding estimator
to an arbitrary value so as an extreme
example for sample app for sample
average the breakdown point is just 1
over N which means that you only need to
change one of the observations so that
you can entirely change the value of the
estimator so that means a sample average
is not robust okay so for quantumwise
media and Tukey's median people have
calculated the breakdown points of their
problem when it's 1 over to the other is
1 over 3 that means you need to change
at least how the data to completely
change the value of the corner median
but for two keys meeting you only need
to do so for a third data so from this
comparison you may think well call it
wise median it's more robust but this is
not the complete story yet well beside
English into the break the breakdown
point that assess the robustness
property we can also look at the static
convergence rates and in particular if
there is no contamination than the
convergence rates with two estimators
are plain feel and you cannot
distinguish them however when there is
contamination and you try to calculate
the rates of convergence and the Huber's
action contamination model then you can
really see the difference between the
rate of convergence especially the
second trend that depends on epsilon the
rates for two keys median is dimension
independent while here you have p times
epsilon squared and this rate it can be
proved to be the minimax
up to rate and the Hoover's epsilon
contamination model so this this this
table tells us that you know by this
very simple example tell us that kubarz
model is the right framework to study a
robust procedure because if you do that
and the Hoover's
you have to study the statistical
property and the robustus properties
simultaneously right if you do these two
things separately but then you will get
a misleading conclusion um you may think
well calling me corny wise median is
actually better but it is not okay so
let me briefly talk about the intuition
behind the definition of Pookie's median
so the idea of John Tukey is that if you
can solve a one-dimensional robust
estimation problem then you can simply
project the data onto all the univariate
direction and then sort of combine the
Univera median into a multivariate media
estimator so let's consider a particular
direction parameterize by a unit vector
U and then just project the data onto
that direction you calculate the
proportion of the data on the right hand
side of this of this number and on the
left hand side of this estimate under
this number try to balance these two
numbers so each one is approximately 1
over 2 which means for a candidate
vector data its projection on this
particular that direction is close to
the sample median or of that of that
particular collection right so this
particular measure is sort of a measures
to outline this of the this this number
on a particular direction so if you take
a minimal overall direction this gives
you an overall outlying measure of the
kennedy vector asa so Pookie's idea is
just just to maximize this objective
function which is called the deepest
point and it's defined as Tukey's media
ok and due to symmetry you can actually
rewrite doctors and function in a
simplified way all right so that's for
the location estimation problem now
let's try to talk about regression for
regression let's talk about this simple
Gaussian linear model where the
conditional distribution of Y given X is
specified by this Gaussian linear model
and then is it possible to robustly
estimate the regression vector beta you
using ideas similar to toki well there
is something called regression depths
and I'm going to introduce its
definition but the first problem you
notice that the observation you'll have
is Y which itself is a scalar so you do
not really have a direction to projector
right you only have a two direction
because it's one-dimensional either
projected to minus 1 or 1 this is not
enough for us to capture the complexity
of beta which itself lives in a P
dimensional space so the first step you
can do is to embed the observe embed the
response variable into ap dimensional
space by taking product between the
covariance and Y and then you will have
AP dimensional regression problem now
you can use tookies idea to project it
back onto a one dimensional subspace and
write down the same in the formula as
two peas media so this gave you the
definition what is known as the
regression depth function the Maximizer
of the regression depths is a robust
regression coefficient estimator and
this is proposed by Russell and Hubert
in 1999 ok so you may think well this is
a more general idea than a two keys
median may be two keys median is a
special case of regression depths but it
is not true - keys media is not a
special case of regression depths these
are different concepts so in order to
understand these two Deb's function you
know from a unified framework we need to
choose our we need to introduce
something even more general called
multitasker brush in depth so here we
actually generalize the regression model
by considering a multitasker regression
setting where not only the covariance is
multivariate but the response is also a
multivariate vector living in there M
dimensional space so this is like you
have n independent regression problem
that you try to solve together and the
goal is to learn the regression
coefficients that can be organized into
a P by M dimensional matrix right so the
the regression depths for this for this
problem it can be defined in the
following way
so let's consider a matrix U that is of
the same size of B that lives in P by M
dimension and then this u transpose Act
will be a M dimensional vector y minus B
transpose X is just the residual that
you can calculate by fitting the linear
model using this matrix B and then the
population version of this multitasks
regression Def's function is defined to
be the infimum over you over the
probability of the inner product between
this u transpose x and the residual is
greater than equal to 0 and then if you
replace this probability by empirical
measure then you get empirical version
of the of the Deaf's function right so
this is a more general version of depths
compared with two key steps and
regression depths and itself is a
special case of something even more
general called tangent depths that is
proposed by mozilla in a 2002 and also
statistic paper ok so some special cases
we can discuss the first case is when P
equals 1 meaning that you have n
response by only one covariate let's
further assume that X the Coverity is 1
then this just gives you the two P steps
okay and the second special case is when
M is 1 so that means you only have it's
just a univariate regression problem
with multivariate a Cole area so that
would use to the regression gaps
function so you can see that the
multitask regression tabs function is
really an extension of both two key taps
and regression depths from different
directions
ok so to understand why it helps you to
estimate things robustly in a minimax
way let's talk about two important
properties of regression depth the first
property is that the deviation yes
version of the death of X given Y
like the I think you can because the
definition doesn't really doesn't really
doesn't really depend on the generated
data at random process it's only where
you estimate the behavior of the
estimator that the GP matters okay so
the first property tells you the
deviation between the population
regression depths and the empirical data
regression depths its deviated by the
difference can be bounded by square root
of P times n divided by n here n is a
sample size and P times n is just the
number of parameters in the model so
this is a simple vc-dimension
calculation and the second property is
the stability property of the multitask
version depths assess that if you have
an epsilon contamination and then the
regression depth can only be changed by
the value of at most Epsilon so
combining these two properties you can
you can actually prove that it actually
achieved a minimax rate if you have the
other judging process like this for
example we consider a ordinary
multitasks regression a problem where
you have a random design which is
assumed to be Gaussian and then given X
Y follows a Gaussian linear model let's
assume the pair of the data are ID
generated from the Hoover's epsilon
contamination model and then the
Maximizer of the regression Deaf's
function can be proved to achieve these
two rates with respect to the prediction
loss and an estimation loss so for
estimation loss you will have an extra
Kappa square which is actually the
smallest eigenvalue of the design matrix
that is kind of necessary and both rates
are the exact minimax rates of the
problem and cannot be further improved
okay so that's for the recursion problem
now let me move to the coherence matrix
problem so it's basically the same thing
that you try to estimate something in
the absent contamination model but this
time is a P by P covariance matrix that
you're trying to estimate so what can
you do
so this is how we can generalize to this
idea to this current maker setting so
our I would like to illustrate the idea
by this picture so suppose we have this
two-dimensional plot of the data point
on a 2 on a 2d surface so again I'm
trying to project my data onto a
one-dimensional direction so let's look
at this direction and on this particular
direction you can actually it's not too
hard it's not hard to figure out the
scale of the data
okay so function like this you can do
that by calculating the median absolute
deviation which is a robust scale
estimator and suppose you can calculate
the median absolute deviation on a
second direction and and then on the
third direction and so on average
direction and then sooner or later you
can realize well the data cloud can be
summarized into a shape of ellipsoid
which then corresponds to a current
matrix estimator so the idea is how to
combine these meeting absolute deviation
from each direction well if you write on
the formula it looks like this so you
first project the data onto the
direction of U and then take it and then
take square compare it to u transpose
gamma u because on that particular
direction
the variance of the data is just u
transpose Sigma u and then this is just
a formula of the median absolute
deviation squared on that particular
direction and take minimum you get what
is called their corns major steps the
Maximizer of it is not a direct estimate
of the Korres matrix you have you have
to scale back by a constant beta that
depends on a Gaussian content function
because you know there is a constant
shift there is a constant difference
between video absolute deviation and
Stata under standard deviation 1 as an
estimator of the point out the other as
estimated of the second moment ok but
then for this particular estimator it
will achieves the minimax rate of the
problem and the Hoover's of some
contamination model with respect to the
square operator all right so here is a
table that we can actually define or
modify depth function to solve other
statical estimation problems for example
you can do that you can do that for
reduced rent regression Gaussian graph
model response PCA using depth function
and for all these problems always with
respect to different loss functions you
can achieve the exact minimax rates of
the problem by using depth functions in
different ways so one common feature of
these mid max rates you can observe that
it always consists of two terms the
first term will always be the minimax
rate when absolutely zero when there is
no contamination and the second term is
always proportional epsilon squared
which depends on something called
modulus continuty that models the
difference between two the variation and
the last function you use okay and these
are all the minimax rates of the problem
that you cannot improve okay so
so we can see that the Deaf's function
is a very useful idea but the practical
question is how do we optimize it right
people have spent years and years trying
to just to just compute two keys median
and they cannot and people people
usually believe this is a and Bihar
tosses you cannot compute and personally
I we also try to compute it by ourself
by writing down the code and to see how
how good or how bad it is we managed to
compute the two expedient when the
dimension is very low the largest
dimension we can cover is when P equals
10 right so when P equals 11 we just
failed week we cannot even get it answer
maybe we wait for another year we will
get the answer but this is very slow
this is not like when you compute error
zero penalize the regression it's it's
calm natori but in practice you can
still do something but for two keys
media or other regressions apps function
you cannot do anything so maybe a more
humble question is as a password I can
design some practically good album that
you can at least use in practice and
have good results that's the go and try
to talk about in a second part network
okay so I also want to mention that for
some specific problems such as the
Gaussian mean estimation there are
amazing developments in recent years now
it is sort of well-known that you can
provably achieve the minimax rate with
where's the actual log base extra poly
logarithmic factor by using this idea of
higher moments that identification that
which are proposed by these authors but
the reason we still want to advocate to
expedient is because of its
indispensable statistical properties
right so I list a few but the most
important property I think is the it's a
third one that the two keys meeting is
not only the optimal for multivariate
Gaussian estimation it is actually
optimal for any literal distribution
right so you can think of a situation
maybe you have a multivariate Koshi
distribution that's the first moment
does not even exist so you cannot
estimate the mean but you still want to
locate the center of the data and then
to Experian also give you an optimal
estimator of the location of the center
of the data right so two keys Media is
designed for estimating the population
mean while the literature the robust
mean estimation estimator in the
literature are designed for estimating
the population mean when mean where
media and mean are different than they
are fundamentally different okay so to
talk about before talking about how how
I can do that
let me first deviate a little bit talk
about the frame of F learning so here
let me first reveal the definition of F
divergence that measures the difference
between two probability measures P and Q
by this formula this is a general notion
of divergence that includes a
chi-squared Aqaba table and total
variations etc as special cases right so
F is a convex function and because of
that you can write f as the supreme of a
bunch of linear functions and this F
star that serves an intercept here is
called the convex conjugate of the
convex function f and if you plug in
this representation you will be able to
obtain the following variational
representation of the F divergence and
this is kind of useful and the optimal
testing function T is achieved when T
takes this form that is when T equals
the derivative of F evaluated at the
likely ratio test between P and Q okay
and since you know the optimal T has to
take this form you you don't have to
take soup
over or tea you only need to take soup
over a class that contains this function
and your variational presentation will
be sharp and in particular since I know
the optimal tea has
take this form I can just take soup over
all functions of this particular form by
replacing P by another key Oh tilde and
then take soup over kill tilde and when
Q tilde equals P the supreme will be
achieved so this is a different version
of the various representations of FFF
divergence we have two different
variations or sensations so for for
these two presentations if you replace
the expected value by the sample average
then this is just the sample that the
sample version of the F divergence that
measures the difference between the
empirical measure and a given
probability Q okay so then you can just
minimize Q to define your estimator and
the first estimate that define in this
way is called Afghan that is proposed by
these people in Microsoft Research and
the second formula does not really have
a name so I just call it f learning to
distinguish from the definition of
Afghan okay so the framework of this F
learning is very general and in
particular if you take F to be the
function that leads to internal
divergence then you are able to recover
the original gain that is proposed by
goodfellas group this is where the deep
learning people start to use again to
the generative distribution for for
images and if you take FX equals x times
log X then you just recover the
definition of Maksim like you estimator
right and if you if you take F that
leads to Haneda Square this is related
to what is known as the role estimator
that is extensively studied by the
French citizens Perot and losing bojay
and finally what is really to us is if
you do total variation then you get the
Deaf's function okay and I'm going to
show you why so let's take F let's take
FX to be the positive part of X minus 1
and then it's derivative is just the
indicator function therefore the total
variation learning formula can be
written in this form okay and for
example if you want to estimate a normal
mean what can
do the only thing you need to need to do
is to specify the two classes of
distribution that you need to deal with
so let's specify the first class
distribution script Q by the normal
location model that's the natural choice
for the second class we also take the
normal location model but the difference
is that we take theta tilde to be only
in the neighborhood of theta with radius
R I'm doing that because you only need
to distinguish data that are close from
the truth okay so once you have this
choices once you have this choice then
I'm going to send the radius R to 0 well
I can obtain from this process is
exactly the definition of to P median ok
so this is kind of interesting because
before that we have a good intuition of
true comedian we understand that it is a
process of projecting data and then try
to calculate a union univariate median
and try and then combine them but this
process tell you that two-piece median
has nothing but the minimizer of a
simple version of total variation
distance and this also explains why it
is a minimax optimal and this Hoover's
absolute contamination model because
Hoover's model essentially miss
specification with respect to total
irish-american distance and what took is
median do what works median does is
exactly try to minimize to the version
distance that's why they are compatible
with each other
ok so you can also do the same thing for
the current matrix estimation and for
this task the first class can be
specified as the current matrix model
and the second class I'm going to
restrict Sigma tilde only in a rank or
neighborhood of Sigma so this is kind of
important because you cannot let Sigma
tilde to be in an arbitrary neighborhood
of Sigma that would be not even Fisher
consistent so there is a subtle here you
have to specify this Ranko neighborhood
and then I'm going to that R goes to 0
what I can obtain as the following
formula so this is very closely related
to the matrix steps function that we
proposed
in 2015 and at that time we do not
understand that so we just proposed
maître snaps functions by following two
keys intuition but now it is sort of
satisfying to know this is just again
okay and you can do the same thing for
the regression model and the regression
def function can be recovered in the
same way so the f learning framework is
actually interesting it sort of gives
you a link between the two areas of
robust statistics and deep learning area
so at least by two directions for the
first direction you can imagine we can
actually borrow those good optimization
procedures from the deep learning
community to to solve those robust
estimation problems and the other
direction you can think of is we have
many good theoretical developments in
robust this community maybe that can
help you to to inspire some of the
theoretical foundation the Rutland ended
for deep learning problem ok all right
so in the in the rest of my talk I'm
going to focus on the second direction
try to convince you why those algorithms
in the deep learning community can be
used to optimize things that is close
the gaps function so since I already
said that to keep median is is the
minimize of total variation distance is
is regarded as a special case of total
version learning we can start with by
looking at this total version again ok
so the definition of total variation
again is trying to distinguish the
empirical distribution from a normal
location model by a logistic regression
classifier the reason I'm using the just
regression classifier is is because this
is the simplest classifier I can think
of so you always start with something
simple and to see if it works so the
good news is that it does work because
both are this formula and tux median can
be regarded as variation low about what
can be regarded as
to optimize variation of the bounds of
total variation distance and this is
even a sharper vibrational lower bound
compared to that of the two keys median
and that's why it works right you can
show that this estimator can also
achieve the minimax rate of the problem
or the bad news is that you cannot
really optimize it optimization is
really hard we try to compute it all by
ourselves
but even if you start your algorithm by
some good initialization in a in a good
regime it will still start to diverge
Wednesday doing this alternating
gradient descent and grading ascent
algorithm and later we try to put the TV
on landscape and then we sort of
understand why it will have this it will
have this very strange behavior so in
one word it does not work so the next
thing we can look at is your session
again because this is the origin again
that people have some success in
learning complicated distributions of
image here my goal is just to learn this
normal location model and how hard is
that right so but you still need to
besides writing down this definition you
still need to specify what kind of
classifier you need to choose
so here before I'm before I tell you the
right classifier to choose first and let
me show you some numerical experiments
so the numerical experiments we generate
ID sample from the mixture model so this
is a Gaussian location model and it's
contaminated by another location model
at the contaminating vector as see the
tilde to distinguish from theta that we
are trying to estimate okay so we try
different classifiers
they are basically neural networks with
different structures and the first in
the first case the neural network has
only one layer so it is equivalent to
the logistic regression in the previous
slides and these structures have some
hidden layers and they sort of have
different behaviors in terms of the
ization there's no problem you can you
can you can code it and if you run it on
GPU
usually it's very fast okay so for the
first classifier what we observe is that
you are always getting optimizer that is
very close to the to the overwhelming
which is the average of the trimming and
contamination me right so this means
that the estimator basically has the
same property as sample average that
means it is not robust well but once you
start to have hidden layers in your new
networks then things get reversed it
works and why so we are trying to
understand this phenomenon so the the
lesson we learn from our numerical
experiments is that a classifier with
hidden layers leads to robustness and we
are trying to understand the reason
Jason how does the constraint on spread
tea translate to constraints on neural
net parameters could you rephrase your
question in the max there's a constraint
there's a function class it's max over
script T will help does that translate
to a constraint on neural net parameters
so for this one the formula is just
given by the same logistic crashing here
right so that's that's the that's the
that's the one they are in your network
if you if you have a two layer network
you you are going to replace this X by
another sigmoid that that's what I mean
by multi-layer neural network it is the
class T there is given by a network
architecture there's no constraints on
the chorion compare there are L l1 and
l2 constraint on coefficients and mostly
I'm using l1 voting here I didn't give a
detail
okay so we are trying to understand why
this phenomena happens and and then we
got an answer so let me define this what
I call the yen's and Shannon divergence
a local version with respect to G right
so this is divergence function between P
and Q that is distinguished by a
logistic regression using the feature G
so G is the multivariate function that
map's a multivariate data from the P
dimensional space to a D dimensional
feature space and that's a then it
defines the divergence function the
proposition we have is that this
diverges function is 0 if and only if
the expected value of G is the same
under both distributions so this means
that if the features are the same under
both distributions then the divergence
is not able to tell the part the
distributions so that in class if you
are trying to minimize the assumption
again you are more or less trying to
match the moments that you have in your
classifier and in the previous
experiments if we use a single layer
network logis regression this is saying
that GX equals x so what you are trying
to match is just the moment of X the
first moment of the data and of course
you will get the empirical average
because that's the empirical first
moment and that's not robust but when
you start to have hidden layers you a
new network what you are actually
matching is the nonlinear moments that's
why it leads to robustness so nonlinear
non-linearity in the neural network is
even a classifier is actually a very
important and we can indeed we can
indeed prove that so for a new network
with at least one hidden layer and a
property recognization as you just asked
we have the following rates of
convergence if you use those bounded
activation functions things will get a
bit easier because it is bounded if you
want to use a real Lu you have to you
can only use that after two top two
layers because it's not bounded but
anyway the rates are almost optimal
except here we have long PDF
okay so that's for a min estimation
using neural Nets
what about unknown covariance so the
previous theorem assumes that coherence
matrix is identity right so what if here
we have an unknown current structure
that we try to adapt to remember two
keys median does not have a problem
that's what that's why we like two keys
median and here what can we do
well there are since there there is a
simple modification that you can just
modify the generator class okay try to
make your January class more general so
replace identity by gamma and then not
only do you maximize over the mean
vector also maximize over the covariance
matrix and then that will work so you do
not need to change the discriminator
class you will eventually get to
estimators feeder hat will still be
minimax optimal for Sigma hat you just
throw it away because it may not be
accurate so here's a general principle
when you try to adapt to nuisance
parameter we're using this gun type
estimator that basically you are you are
free to modify the generator class it
will not affect the static complex the
other of the problem that signal
compacity is only determined by the
discredit cost okay and you can think of
the situation that we want to adapt to
an elliptical distribution what you can
do is to modify the generator class to
have to incorporate that and thank you
and then not only you can maximize over
these four two parameters or you can
also maximize over at the marginal shape
of an under constitutional and that will
also work and i'm not going to introduce
you so the last topic i'm trying to
cover is some ongoing work for
estimating currents matrix using this
idea so again you can write down the
again of the ganth formula for
estimating the Korres matrix by by using
this generator class so here for
simplicity let's assume that ming is
zero so i'm only going to specify the
classifier that the class of
discriminator to to define estimator so
i'm going to tell you to
that do not work and then I'm going to
tell you some simple modification for
the two classes that actually work so
here are two classes that do not work so
the first class is a two layer sigmoid
neural network this class will not work
it's kind of surprising because you know
this class we prove it is optimal for
min estimation but for Cohen's major
stagnation this is not consistent right
and the second class is a single
modification you change the
non-linearity of the of the hidden layer
to reduce and that's things were getting
better because if there is no
contamination it actually works it's
optimal but the problem is that it is
not robust okay so these are two current
examples that you that work but actually
you can make simple modification to make
it work so for the first class the only
thing you need to do is to add an extra
intercept in neuron right so at a 1 here
and then it will work you know when
people model data by neural networks
adding a intercept or not is really a
matter of whether you standardize your
data or not right it's not essential but
here it is so fundamental it will
determine whether things work or not and
if you want to use a raloo activation
function what you can modify is to add
actual hidden layer in front of it then
it will work so this 3 layer structure
also works for clients matrix estimation
and for above to your next class we can
prove that resulting estimator achieves
a minimax rate with respect to the
squared operator norm ok so here's some
numerical performance we try to record a
time against the dimension remember
previous that I told you that for two
keys median it only works for P equals
ten but now if I found that no problem
and seems to grow well right so we are
satisfied waste
crackle performance okay I think I'll
stop here and questions what is
intuition behind so you change the
architecture of the artwork sometimes
it's it's basically the proposition I
showed that that says that the
minimizing can is more or less like
matching the moments so if you know what
kind of moments you need to match in a
robust way then you can do reverse
engineering to transit into your lattice
structure you don't have to use new
network as long as but at least for the
norming for the norming estimation
setting I think that today and another
is the most natural classifier because
the proposition says that whatever
feature you start to use from the second
layer will be the moment you match right
and and Tukey's idea is that you you
need to match the first moment for each
each different direction and if you add
a sigmoid that will give you
non-linearity put it on the second layer
that will give you the to layer new data
structure
I was in your generator why is it always
the generator is only two mixtures of
Gaussian to your generator it was always
just mixture of two gaussians why is
that
I thought the contamination model was
anything I know the contamination model
it can be can be any distribution so
when I when I say I have a mixture of
two Gaussian this is just a numerical
experiment I just I just told you I have
found this numerical experiment and
here's my observation but later when I
prove theorem that's for any
contamination when you implemented that
generator is a mixture of two gaussians
yeah where the theorem is anything yeah
that's right but the discriminator is in
your own net for the field that's right
the generators I've read okay
in this formula you have the average of
Baretta not 1 minus T of X can you
compute this analytically for any clear
or use sample and what people do in the
different literature is to be because
you can send home from distribution is
to replace this rotation by a simple
average and then you can use screening
tests and aggregates and to do that so
this method how I don't I'd use it to
the assumption that the so so you can
you can generalize that by making that a
sweeter more general right so if if you
want to include all individual
distribution then try to optimize
overall a liquid extrusions here if you
want to incorporate or cigars in this
region that you also need to do here so
it cannot be it cannot be adaptive to
any distribution that that are not
specified in the gender in the generator
class that is very important if you
don't have to know if you do not know
that optimize orbit the the message is
that it does not affect the system
complexity the complexity is only
affected by the class of the
discriminator so here it's really IFI
the viability problem as long as you
make him you know you can make an
arbitrary general as long as things are
viable it would be fine
so if I understand you show good quality
results when you are a twin the when
your model is at the global optimum
that's right so how do you know that
you're at the global Optima and how do
you know how long it's going to take you
to get to it yeah okay so I'm going to
just throw the question to these people
I don't have an answer honestly it's
just a matter of experience and the tuna
is it can you get any idea of what least
what the least favorable should be sure
cube looks like okay ordinary robot
statistics for example yes okay so I
cannot tell you the exact least favorite
queue look like look like but for this
class we have experience right so if you
do yes shine again the least favorite
YouTube see the Tuda is that is very
close to theta
it's about absalom away from theta but
not for total variation again so for for
total variation gasps it's actually the
further the contamination the harder it
is because if it's very far the
landscape becomes becomes a problem than
it was to be stuck at local which will
cause a problem so depending on last
function I think what you're really
asking is in terms of information is
radically but that I don't know okay
there is no other question
[Music]
[Applause]